Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank"...
There's a new sports
drink in town,
and she's got game.
[ Laughs ]
Walsh: I don't know about
you, Sharks,
but when I win,
I want everyone to know.
Whoo!
Oh.
We have sold
a little over $2,000.
$2,000?
Greiner: Whoa!
I think you need a job.
This is our full‐time job
right now.
That's not good,
guys.
[ Sniffles ]
Can I ‐‐
Can I ‐‐ Can I ‐‐
Can I...
God, I just
want to ‐‐
Can I just
tell you a story?
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is an entrepreneur
who is ready to take on
a competitive market.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks. I'm Fran Harris
from Dallas, Texas.
Hooooo!
Yeah!
And I'm seeking
$350,000
in exchange for 20%
of my company.
Sharks, the sports drink
category
is a $23 billion opportunity.
The problem is that
a lot of these companies
who are purporting to have
"functional hydration"
are actually
putting water in bottles
that are full of
nothing more than sugar...
...artificial colors
and ingredients...
...and, you guessed it, salt.
Sharks,
consumers are not going to
settle for a sports drink
that over‐promises
and under‐delivers,
leaving you feeling tired
and sluggish.
You know why?
Why?
Why?                        Why?
Because there's
a new sports drink in town,
and she's got game.
Introducing Electra,
a better‐for‐you functional
beverage hydration company
that's going to change
the sports drink game forever.
Sharks, I played
on an undefeated Division I
women's basketball team
at The University of Texas.
I also played on the WNBA's
first championship team
with the Houston Comets.
So safe to say I've consumed
a lot of hydration
and sports drinks.
And I can tell you
without a doubt
that everyday athletes,
hustlers, and doers,
what they're looking for,
an Electra delivers
on every single one of those.
And yeah, there's
some competition out there.
But let me tell you, Sharks,
we are coming for that ass.
[ Laughter ]
So, there's really only
one question remaining.
Who's ready to electrify
their hustle,
end the tyranny
of these sugary sports drinks,
and help me raise
this billion‐dollar baby?
[ Chuckles ]
Good job.
Corcoran:
Great. Great pitch.
Are we going to try these?
Yes, you are going to try those.
So, those are the three flavors.
There is Litty Lemonade,
there is Passion Punch,
and there is "Oh, Yeah!" Orange.
Passion Punch is good.
Is there a particular
top seller?
So, those are
our launch flavors.
You haven't sold
any yet?
Good question, Kevin.
[ Laughs ]
Already you show
how wonderful you are.
No, we haven't sold them.
We literally just launched
about 10 days ago.
Wow.
Okay?
What do you use
to sweeten it?
We are using monk fruit
to sweeten it.
The question that we will
get to either sooner or later...
Mm‐hmm.
...is you mentioned
a few competitors.
Now, they're not just
ordinary competitors.
They are bone‐crushing monsters
who own this category.
What is the plan for you
to get distribution
in the bone‐crushing
business...
Bone‐crushing.
...of sports beverages?
Well, Kevin,
you heard my background.
I'm not afraid
of competitors.
I've competed all of my life.
Yeah. And she's
not afraid of you, Kevin.
And competition
is a good thing.
The plan is to go direct
to consumer online, but ‐‐
Shipping...
a 12‐pound box?
That's going to be
expensive.
Let me finish.
The plan is to go
direct to consumer
as well as to go to retail.
My background is
I was a salesperson
for Procter & Gamble,
so I'm very familiar,
have a lot of experience
in the CPG market.
So I get the freight. I get
how expensive it's going to be.
But I also believe that you have
to go direct to consumer
because there are a lot
of consumers online
who are looking for hydration,
and we need to be there
just like we need to be there
in retail.
So, why did you decide
to go with a drink
as opposed to a mix?
Because once you are hustling
and you're active,
you want to walk into
a convenience store or store
and you want to
grab something then, right?
You don't want to grab a water
and then grab your mix
and then have to do all that.
But I think the convenience
factor is a big thing.
And I get that.
It's just getting
that space...
Totally.
...in the cooler, right,
is hard,
and then trying to be
direct to consumer...
Sure.
...is even harder
'cause of shipping costs.
You've got to be mixed
direct to consumer.
That's a 24‐pound case, 12.
That'll weigh 24 pounds.
‐Agree.
Agree. I think it's important
to be both.
I think it's important
to be on shelf,
and I think it's important
to have a mix
that people can order online.
The shipping's gonna be less.
As somebody
who works out,
I always have to
replenish potassium.
So, the amount
of potassium
relative to
the amount of calories
is really good.
Thank you.
So, that's a positive.
My challenge is, though,
with the Mavs,
I already have two big deals
with sports drink manufacturers.
Okay.
So, I can't touch
anything at all.
But I just got to tell you,
the formulation is great,
the taste is great,
but unfortunately
for those reasons, I'm out.
Are you working full time
on this now?
I am.
Where are you
manufacturing this?
So, we manufacture it in a
little place called Coppell,
which is right outside
of Dallas.
Are you going to be using
a distributor?
Yes, we actually just ‐‐
I got an e‐mail today
from one of the largest
distributors
who wants to see
a sale sheet on it
because I dropped
some of it off last week.
And what is your first
production run going to be?
The first production
run will probably be
between 20,000 or 30,000.
And where are you getting
that money from?
We have some at that meeting,
and hopefully the rest of it
will come from
this little audience right here.
So, you can't
take that product in
until you get the money
from us, right?
That's right.
Good job, Barbara.
Fran, how would you spend
the $350,000?
Could you break
that down for me?
Production will probably
be somewhere
between $20,000 and $30,000.
Okay?
In terms of R&D,
probably $25,000 or something
like that, however that goes.
So, a total of
about $50,000.
And the rest of the money,
what would you do with that?
So I would also hire someone for
logistics, sales, and marketing.
Greiner: So, first of all,
I love you
because I love
your straightforwardness
and your strength
and your confidence.
I would be uber excited
about you,
but the drinks themselves
aren't really my cup of tea.
And so for those reasons,
I'm out.
You're out?
Thank you, Lori.
O'Leary: You have a very
impressive background.
Your pitch was flawless.
There is no data on
sell‐through here, Fran.
You are running, and you want
to take my $350,000...
I do.
...and experiment on...
"I do.
Absolutely, I do."
...whether this
can work or not.
You don't have enough data
to do that.
I don't want to
discourage you,
but I also don't want to
see you crash and burn.
Confidence is not enough.
I hear what you're saying.
First of all, I win.
All I do is win.
So, even though
I'm new in this category,
I'm going to continue
because I know
that I'm going to be able
to carve out
a niche place for Electra,
and then we're going to win.
We are coming for that ass.
That's it.
[ Laughter ]
Okay? Alright.
Any other category, any other
product, anything else,
that kind of, you know,
confidence would be very useful.
Look, I wish you the best.
I really do.
That's alright.
But I'm not taking
this ride with you.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
So, okay.
Turns out you're not
so Mr. Wonderful.
Thank you for that.
Oh. Oh. Oh!
Corcoran: Whoa.
Daymond.
I don't want to agree
with Kevin,
but I've had a lot of challenges
with this area,
and I just wouldn't be able
to help you with this
'cause it's just
so difficult.
So, I'm out.
Okay, thank you, Daymond.
Barbara,
it's just me and you.
CORCORAN: It's okay.
I don't mind an empty room.
That's a lot.
Yeah.
I wish
you hadn't come in here
and pitched
a beverage business.
I rarely agree with Kevin,
but I do.
It's the worst
possible space.
The very first money
I lost on "Shark Tank"
was to a small company guy
with fire in his belly,
great conviction, right
formulation named Chill Soda.
I lost that money
in a month. Boom!
So, it's
a terrible space.
So, for you to stand here
and be so fearless,
you're a hell of a salesman.
When I heard that pitch,
there wasn't
a single word wasted.
But I'm not willing
to risk $350,000.
I'll tell you
what I'll do.
I'll give you $100,000
cash up front,
a $250,000
line of credit.
But because it's
a high risk deal,
I want 40%
of the business.
‐Yowza. Yowza.
‐Ooh!
Now who's wearing
the rings?
‐Ohh!
‐Ohh.
Who's getting
that ass now?
Barbara.
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
Barbara is Fran's last chance
for a deal
for her sports drink company,
Electra,
but she wants a much bigger
stake in the business
than the 20%
Fran came in offering.
I'll give you $100,000
cash up front,
a $250,000
line of credit.
But because it's
a high risk deal,
I want 40%
of the business.
‐Yowza. Yowza.
‐Ooh!
Who's getting
that ass now?
Barbara, I really, really,
really appreciate that offer.
And I can't tell you this
until we decide whether
we're gonna work together,
but I have some things
that are in place.
You might
want to tell me now.
I should tell you now?
You think so?
Oh, yeah.
It's "do lose."
I do have
a couple of Hall of Famers.
One is an NFL Hall of Famer,
one is an NBA hall of Famer
who are ready
to come to the table
to bring their influence
to move this product.
Not their cash.
Both of them are cash.
Well, then.
Yes, both of them
are cash.
Good for you.
So I told them that ‐‐
Thank you for hiding that
until everybody was out.
See? I wanted to see
who was with me, Barbara.
I wanted to see
who was with me.
Maybe.
And these are real offers
that are on the table.
So, I like your offer,
but not for 40%.
Would you be willing
to take
25% for the same deal,
and we have a deal?
I'll give you ‐‐
or I'll take 30%
if you could bring
those two big fish in with us.
And if not,
all bets are off.
So if I can't get both of them
in, you're out completely?
If you don't
bring them in,
you don't get
the $100,000,
the credit line.
You're going to have to take
a gamble yourself here.
But I think
that's only fair
because I'm taking
a huge gamble myself.
So, I'm not sure
that I want both of them.
Oh, you're not sure?
That I want both of them.
I can get both of them.
I'm going to trust you that
if you could get the good one,
then yes,
I'll do that.
But if you don't get them,
you don't get anything.
You'll do, what,
30%, Barbara?
Yeah, 30%.
You bring
the big fish in,
and still, the structure
of my deal is the same ‐‐
$100,000 with
$250,000 credit line.
You drive a hard bargain,
Barbara.
Say yes.
It's a good deal.
But she has no choice.
Yeah, she has
no choice.
What did you say, Mark?
I just said
it's a great deal.
He said
you had no choice.
I always have a choice.
There's no choice
when it comes to Barbara.
I always have a choice.
I love the deal, and I'll take
your deal, Barbara.
You got it, baby.
I wish I could hug you,
but I can't, but let's go!
CORCORAN: I'll make up
for it later, all the hugs.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
Cuban: Congratulations.
Greiner:
Congratulations.
Thank you very much.
When Barbara makes an offer,
you have no choice.
You have to
take that deal.
Whoo!
There's no question ‐‐
beverages are difficult,
but all I've done
all my life is win.
And with Barbara on board,
I know I'll keep winning.
Whoo!
We are coming for that ass!
I think it's a good deal.
You know,
you only get to live once.
Why live in Hell?
So they can
hang out with you, Kevin.
Come on!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Narrator: In season 10,
Anna Skaya made a deal
with Kevin O'Leary
for Basepaws,
a DNA testing kit for cats.
Let's do it.
Cuban: Alright!
Narrator:
Let's see what she's up to now.
Skaya:
A DNA test from Basepaws can
tell you about your pet's breed.
It can look into
their genetic health.
It's like a window
into your pet's soul.
Kevin invited us
to his summit in Miami,
where we got a chance to meet
the top managers
of Amazon Launchpad
and Facebook.
This led to being featured
on Facebook's Boost My Business,
And we're selling more than
25% of all our kits
on Amazon because of Kevin.
When I pitched to the Sharks,
we'd made $200,000 in sales.
In just a year and a half
since "Shark Tank,"
we've done $3.5 million
in sales.
I love cats because
they're customers now.
They're fantastic.
I invested in Anna for Anna.
She's so good
at promoting her products.
She has built that business
tenfold since "Shark Tank."
Skaya: Our goal is to be
a cat health company.
We're doing important work
in feline cancer,
feline diabetes, in the hopes
of helping create therapeutics
to make sure that our cats
are staying healthy.
With 100 million cats
in America,
more people learning about
this product is what matters.
More social media.
There's 100 million customers.
That's a
fantastic market.
Absolutely.
O'Leary:
One thing I've learned about
the whole Basepaws experience
is people love their pets,
and I think what Anna's done
is allowed people
to learn more about an animal
they can't actually
communicate with.
But now they can through DNA.
They can there forecast
the future
of how to keep it
healthier longer
and give it a better life
in their own home.
Skaya:
I feel so proud to be here
talking about our growth
over the last year and a half.
So many times I looked
at this company and thought,
"Can we really do it?"
But between our team,
our community, our pet parents,
we have really proven
that there is a huge market
in the cat business.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a solution
for our sedentary lifestyles.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Bing Howenstein,
and I'm the CEO of All33.
I'm here today
to ask for $500,000
for a 2.5% ‐‐
Hello.
Corcoran: Wow.
...piece of our company.
Bing, baby!
I know
it is a very serious ask,
but that's because it is for a
very serious problem ‐‐ chairs.
They may be killing you.
Now, you've all heard,
sitting is the new smoking.
Well, they are right.
Sitting for any length
and period of time
is really bad for you,
and chairs, well, they've had
the same basic design
for almost 3,000 years.
Whatever you're sitting in,
even the fancy expensive chairs
you guys are sitting in
right now,
you can find yourself
locked, stuck, immobile,
and, a lot of times, in pain.
And for all of us
working at home these days,
this is just not okay.
Well, I have some
really good news for you.
Corcoran: Oh!
[ Chuckles ]
Whoa!
All33 is here
to save the day,
but don't just take it
from me.
Let's hear what one of our
biggest fans has to say.
Hey, Sharks.
I'm Justin Bieber,
and this is the All33.
It's the chair
that moves like I do.
I mean, guys, look at
this perfect posture.
Got my chest up,
my shoulders back.
I'm ready for anything.
I mean, have you guys
ever seen a chair
that can do this?
I'm doing a full
ab workout right now.
Alright. Hit me up later.
I'll be back.
If you got to sit,
this is it.
Now, Justin knows
what he's talking about
because this is our patented
Sit‐In‐Motion Technology.
It's like a chair
within a chair,
and it rocks,
just like our sales.
Now, you don't have to have
moves like Justin
in order for this chair
to work for you,
because all you have
to do is sit,
get fit,
and All33 of your vertebrae,
well, they're going to
keep moving all day.
Now, this is a chair.
Now, Mr. Wonderful...
Yes.
...you're looking particularly
uncomfortable.
I am.
Would you like to come up
and take a seat...
I would.
...and see what
we're talking about?
I have a bad back
from a squash injury.
Oh, well, then,
let's see what happens.
Howenstein:
Make sure you get your behind
all the way
into the back of the chair.
Scooch back there.
Alright.
And you can probably feel
the rocking motion
move back and forth.
Very interesting.
Why is this
making me sit up straight?
Why does that happen?
So, the patents that we have
about this
are really quite unique.
Basically,
Dr. Dennis Colonello,
who invented this,
he's been doing this
for a long, long time ‐‐
he's got 45 years
of treating backs, necks,
and everything else ‐‐
he figured out,
let's get
your hips moving,
almost as if ‐‐
what you're experiencing
is a sensation that's almost
like you're standing,
but when you're sitting.
It is moving all 33 of your
vertebrae while you're sitting,
and there's nothing else
in the world that is doing it.
I'm very skeptical about
all these claims on chairs
'cause I've tried
so many,
and I also have tried different
devices to help my back.
This thing actually
is working.
I don't care
about Bieber.
I'm going to kick his ass
when my album comes out.
[ Laughs ]
I don't like
your valuation, though.
Well, we can
talk about that.
Yeah.
I would expect
that from you.
Tell us, how did you get
into this, and what happened?
So, I have been a patient
of Dr. Colonello's
for about 20 years
and then friend.
I'm also a bit
of a serial entrepreneur.
I got into making products
and getting products sold.
Along the way, I got into
the back care space.
When I sat on Dennis' chair,
an early prototype,
I said, "This is
a whole different ball game."
But I knew that Dennis was never
going to get this thing going.
As a friend, I said,
"Let me help you.
I'm going to do
a Kickstarter for you."
So, we did that.
It performed very well.
What's very well?
We did $800,000.
That's very well.
That's great.
Did you license it from him?
Are you
partners with him?
Howenstein: No, no, no.
I own a small piece of it.
How much of the company
do you own?
I own about 5%.
So, a premium chair
in today's market
sells for roughly $2,000,
a real premium chair.
What does this sell for?
We're selling this for $799.
What's your margin?
What's it cost you to make?
So, our margin's around 67%.
Our cost delivered to a customer
with all that good stuff
is about 260 bucks.
2.5%. $500,000.
$20 million valuation.
Yep.
How many chairs are you selling?
How many dollars?
So, this year alone, we've sold
about 3.2 million.
We're on track to hit
five and a half.
Okay, and what are you going to
make on five and a half?
So, we were slightly profitable
in the second quarter,
and we expect to be the same
in this third quarter.
I mean, just help me
because, you know,
I'm a quick study
in most sectors...
Sure.
...office supply, furniture,
or even,
if you want to call this
high‐end chair design, whatever.
Maybe it would trade for
11 times pretax cash flow.
I mean, I'm not saying
it isn't a great chair,
but it's a chair.
Yeah.
Why is it worth
$20 million?
We are looking at comps
for other companies
that are out there
in a very similar space
that are three to four times
revenue.
We know we're going to
get there.
We have also talked
to the market. Not my opinion.
20 million bucks
is a pretty good valuation.
So, then why
are you here?
Why am I here?
If you talked to so many people
that gave you that valuation,
why are you here?
Because Shark money
is better than other money.
So, you're charging
us more than...
No.
...your sales
because we're Sharks?
I'm prepared to give you
a discount
because you guys
are Sharks.
Can you give a discount?
I am the CEO of the company,
and I'm here to make a deal.
You're a marketing company,
first and foremost.
You've got
your product, right?
It's got its angle.
It's got its differentiation.
Sure.
And that's good,
right?
I just don't want to be
in the chair business.
Sure.
You know?
It's just ‐‐
Of all the businesses,
big and small,
not that there's anything wrong
with the chair business,
but it's just not for me.
Okay.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
That's fair.
Thank you.
If you had
come in here today
and you wanted to
sell me a chair,
you're the perfect guy.
But you weren't here
to sell a chair.
You here to sell
a business.
Correct.
And you said you're
a 5% owner?
Correct.
I, for some reason,
feel it lacks credibility.
Okay.
I think that's a good lesson
for other entrepreneurs.
You can't
send a salesman in.
Well, with all due respect,
this is my life right now,
and to ‐‐ it's a bit
of a denigration to call me
a simple salesman on this deal.
Barbara's very good
at pissing everybody off.
Well, that's fair,
and you can do that.
But the fact is,
that is not
what is happening here.
I'm here to build a company.
We are building a movement
in a category
that hasn't been done before.
We're going up against
the big guys
that, you know, frankly,
it's a fractured system
that I look forward to breaking.
I wish I could believe
that you're building a category,
but I don't see that
as a category.
I see it as a chair
with a new design element.
Well ‐‐
It doesn't get me
all excited.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you.
Greiner: The problem for me
is whenever somebody comes in
and they have
something different
that can really be good,
but they're just starting...
Yeah.
...and they want
to get a Shark,
I always feel
the smart thing to do
is to be a lot smarter
about your valuation,
because if you get somebody
in and alongside with you,
you could take a one‐off item
like this and blow it up,
which is what
I'm good at.
Sure.
So, if you had had something
that was just more realistic ‐‐
because I just feel
it's so out of whack.
For me,
it just turns me off.
And for that reason,
unfortunately, I'm out.
That's fair.
There is a competitor company
that just had a
$200 million valuation
on, you know,
just a little higher sales.
I actually work
with one of the bigger guys,
Varidesk.
Sure.
And the whole theory
is the desks raise up
and the chairs that they sell
are a little pole, a chair,
so you have to
balance yourself.
Sure.
This would be
a conflict with me.
So I'm out.
I started choking
on the valuation,
and I'm still
choking on it.
Okay.
I tried the chair,
and it has merit.
But 500K for 2.5%?
I don't get out of bed
for 2.5%.
Bing, I can't do it.
Well, I'm more than happy to
have you on a higher place
in the cap table,
with just a little more money.
I don't want to beat you up.
My routine would be
to squeeze your head
like a teenage pimple,
and I feel like doing that...
[ Laughs ]
...but I don't want to,
so I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
I will buy one,
though.
Well, you're going to have
to pay full price this time.
I guess I will.
Oh. Bam!
Alright.
Thank you, Bing.
To have Barbara
just call me a salesman,
I think that was
a bit offensive,
and I don't think any
entrepreneur wants to hear that.
When you put your blood,
sweat, and tears into something,
I find that particularly,
you know, not cool.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a product
to spice up your life.
♪♪
Both: Hey, Sharks!
I'm Jennifer.
And I'm Michael.
And we're here to turn you on
with His & Her Bar.
An aphrodisiac bar.
And we're seeking
$50,000
in exchange for 10%
equity in our company.
But Sharks,
how about a little music
to get you in the mood?
One, two, three, hit it.
[ Rapping ] ♪ His & Her Bar,
baby, 'bout to represent ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Every ingredient,
aphrodisiac ♪
♪ All natural and spicy,
just a little hint ♪
♪ Vegan and gluten free,
not a coincidence ♪
♪ Bring couples together,
so provident ♪
♪ Not a small time, bro,
we're going monument ♪
♪ Package looking so plush,
so opulent ♪
♪ Best money in the world
that I ever spent ♪
♪ Partner up with a Shark,
that's a compliment ♪
♪ Wake up in the morning,
do it all again ♪
♪ Whoo! ♪
Wow.
Let me break it down
for you real quick.
His & Her Bar
is the most fun...
Sexy, interactive
food product around town.
We use seven aphrodisiac
super foods
that will stimulate
sexual desire
and bring you and your partner
closer together.
Okay, that's what
I'm talking about.
Our bars will want to
make you have sexy times
and do the mattress mambo.
Or should we say
the pants‐off dance‐off.
[ Laughs ]
And based on our personal
experience,
let's just say...
Both:
These bars work!
So, Sharks,
one more time for you.
♪ Our bars or will make you move
around the set, set ♪
♪ We're looking for $50,000
at 10% ♪
♪ Best money in the world
that you'll ever spend ♪
So, Sharks,
for your tasting pleasure,
we have some
sexy treats for you.
Oh, yeah.
Cuban: That's pretty good.
So, you can pick up your bar,
and we'll do a little cheers.
Cheers.
O'Leary: Cheers.
Cuban: Cheers.
John: Cheers!
I'm nervous
Barbara's gonna jump me.
[ Laughter ]
Jennifer: So, as you're
consuming the bar,
it's going to have
a creamy consistency
with an earthy
and nutty flavor.
That's gonna come
from the ‐‐
Oh, it's spicy, too.
Got a little
spice in there.
Exactly.
Is there any difference
in the formulation
between his and hers?
All the ingredients collectively
are good for him and for her.
It is really
spicy, though.
Yeah, so, you're going to have
a little hint
of cayenne at the end.
When you get to where
you get that little hint ‐‐
Little hint?
No, that's a spice.
That's a spice?
How many calories
are we talking about here?
So, the bar has
220 calories.
Cuban: Damn.
That's a lot of calories.
Whoa!
It's all natural, though.
It doesn't taste
so sweet, though, at all.
Well, you're going to burn
those calories off.
Exactly.
Maca ‐‐ Actually, maca is
a Peruvian sweet root vegetable,
and in Peru, maca is known
as the Peruvian Viagra.
So, it really just depends.
Really?
Yeah.
How much maca
is in this?
Michael:
So, for each bar,
there's 0.7 ounces
of maca per bar.
How much in advance
do you eat it,
and are you suggesting
somebody should eat a whole one?
So, it's meant to be
like a lifestyle bar.
So, with Michael and I,
like, we like
to enjoy it together.
We call it
sexy snack time.
And, you know, sexy snack time
doesn't always have to mean
that it's going to
allude to sex, right?
It's about that connection,
and right now in today's world,
people are craving
that connection.
Do you have children?
We don't.
We do not have children.
Well, that explains
an awful lot.
A whole lot.
Can you tell me how you came up
with the idea? It's crazy.
So I served in the Navy.
Thank you
for your service.
Michael: Thank you.
I appreciate it.
So, fast forward
to 2015,
we live in South Florida,
and I get hired on
as a firefighter.
And one of the things
I was excited about
being a firefighter
was the brotherhood,
the connection.
Maybe I remembered that
from my time in the military.
And as a few months
went by,
I started to notice
that I couldn't connect
with the people
in the department.
So, a few months pass.
Chief brings me
in the office and he lets me go
for basically not being able
to fit in with the crew.
And I'll never forget,
I'm on my way home that day,
and I hadn't even told
Jennifer what happened,
and I'm trying to figure
everything out,
and I go to get gas
for the car,
and on the top of the gas pump
is a rock,
and there's writing
on the rock,
and the rock said ‐‐
I picked the rock up
and it said,
"Just when the caterpillar
thought the world was over,
it became a butterfly."
True story.
So, you get home to Jennifer,
you say, "I met a rock,
and it talked to me."
I said, "Babe."
And she said,
"I got to dump this guy."
[ Laughs ]
I know, right? It's kind of
cheesy for a firefighter.
You know what, though?
We're very serendipitous.
So, a little bit about myself.
I graduated from
the University
of South Carolina,
and I went to the wonderful
world of corporate America
and soon to find out
that it was not for me.
I did really well in the job,
but something was missing.
So in 2015, I left
my six‐figure corporate job,
I cashed in my 401k
and my savings,
and I went all in
to start an activewear brand.
Oh, no competition
there.
[ Chuckles ]
Yeah, well, exactly.
I learned a lot of lessons.
But Michael's job,
when he was doing his job right,
it was supporting us because
it was money in, money out.
It was a very capital
intensive business.
So, basically when Michael lost
his job, we needed to pivot.
So, we ended up
selling our house
because it was about
to go into foreclosure.
Oh, my.
We moved across country
from South Florida
to Scottsdale, Arizona,
to basically hit
the reset button.
So, in January 2019,
I wrote down an intention
to create a product
that would be regularly consumed
and better the lives
of other people.
Is that this product?
This is this product.
Okay, so...
But we didn't launch
until June this year.
Reason being ‐‐
So, let's talk sales.
So, we have sold
500 bars.
How many dollars
is that?
A little over
$2,000.
I just went limp.
$2,000?
You got to be kidding.
So, let me just
tell you right now. So...
Oh, my ‐‐ $2,000?!
Okay, we knew you would
say that, Mr. Wonderful.
We were waiting for
this moment.
$2,000?!
Kevin, how excited
are you right now?
I'm not!
Have we forgotten
what we're in right now?
I'm not trying
to come up with excuses,
but we are in the middle
of a very challenging
time in business, right?
But you knew the problems
that were out there, Jennifer,
'cause you've been
through a launch
before with
your activewear, right?
Jennifer: Totally.
And you know
how expensive it is
and you know how important it is
to have a receptive market.
Why did you launch it at all
and why not wait?
Good question. So we were
actually working in a restaurant
while we were building
our business.
And so, in March,
we got furloughed.
Even worse.
Even worse, I mean, because
now you have to buy inventory.
Right?
You have to do marketing.
That's obviously
why we're here, right?
We need to be able to build
the brand recognition.
I think you need a job.
Cuban: You do need a job.
No, I mean ‐‐
This is
our full‐time job right now.
That's not good, guys.
You've already
had to downsize.
You've already had
to sell your house.
Yeah.
You're allowed to have
a job while you have a company,
and you can still be completely
committed to your company.
I worked as a bartender
at night.
Yeah.
I worked at Red Lobster
for five years
while I started FUBU.
Michael, this is just too early
for an investment.
And I have to relate
to a product.
I just don't relate to it,
and I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
You know,
I probably need this product
more than any other woman
on Earth.
I haven't had a sexual thought
in probably 30 years.
[ Laughter ]
But I'm going to try
this product.
But I want to address something
other than the product.
I've noticed a lot of people
start businesses
after they're fired,
as though that's also a rock
or a message that you get.
Like, "Oh, I should be
working for myself."
It doesn't mean that at all.
It's supposed to mean,
"I should get another job."
I really wish you
the best of luck, but I'm out.
We have enough expenses
to cover
our living expenses
for the rest of our lease.
Greiner:
Let me talk to that, okay?
Okay.
So, every
entrepreneur thinks
they're going to create
the next best thing.
But you have to
remember something.
Not every idea you have is going
to be that perfect winner
right out of the gate.
But you keep creating,
and you have no idea
if that next thing is going to
be your million dollar idea,
because it could be.
And I'm a firm believer,
and I've seen it happen a lot.
But because I don't think this
one's your million dollar idea,
I'm sorry, I'm out.
O'Leary: This isn't
a business yet.
One of you has to get a job
just to have the safety net.
♪♪
Just ‐‐ [ Sighs ]
Just tell the story.
You got it.
It's okay.
Can I ‐‐
Can I ‐‐ Can I ‐‐
Can I...
God, I just
want to ‐‐
Can I just
tell you a story?
Narrator: Three Sharks are out.
Michael is getting emotional
pitching his and Jennifer's
aphrodisiac bar, His & Her.
Michael: [ Voice breaking ]
God, I just want to ‐‐
Can I just
tell you a story?
When I was growing up,
I want to be a firefighter,
and I go through
the fire academy
and I fail,
and I'm determined,
right?
So, about
a few months before...
...I'm supposed to go
into my second fire academy,
I start ‐‐ I start getting
these headaches
and, um, I don't know
where they're coming from.
And I go to the VA, right?
I get it checked out, you know?
And the next day,
they call me back
and they tell me that they found
a small brain aneurysm.
And I still have it
right now.
Look, Michael,
you got to remember something ‐‐
as entrepreneurs,
we fail multiple times,
multiple times,
over and over again.
I've lost millions of dollars
with bad ideas
I didn't know were bad
'til I realized
they didn't work.
The hallmark
of an entrepreneur ‐‐
you've got to pick yourselves up
and you got to get going again.
You know what?
I understand.
We're over here
and you're over there,
and we need more
than just finance,
than just connections.
We need mentorships.
We need a strategic partner.
This is what we need.
I'm staying focused
on the fact
that this is
an investment opportunity.
I'm not saying
you're not fantastic people,
but this is not investable.
I'm out.
What I'll tell you is
that we have grit.
I've been called crazy,
delusional,
that I need to, you know,
I need to give up, right?
If I gave up,
I wouldn't be here today.
Cuban: Look, guys, how much
do you have in inventory?
We make as we go.
Smart.
Look, you're in
the circumstances you're in.
I don't question your heart.
I don't question your desire.
I don't question
your authenticity.
Every one of us has had
our backs against the wall.
I can't tell you how many times
I was so stressed,
if ate 50 of these,
it wouldn't change my sex life.
But things happen. So you'll
figure out your personal side.
You'll figure out
the job side of it.
Right? You don't need to spend
any more money on this.
So, keep on fighting like
you're fighting, build to order.
You guys can do this.
I'm not going to invest
because you're not ready.
In your lives,
you're not ready yet.
Product wise,
So, guys, I'm out.
Good luck, guys.
Alright. Just so you guys know,
one thing really quick is
that we didn't get to talk
about the vision for the brand.
It's not just
a one‐hit wonder.
We're going to be
doing other bars.
At this point, that's not
what it's about.
Not for any of us, because
it's got to be investable.
O'Leary: I wish you
the best of luck, okay?
John: Good luck, guys.
Cuban: Good luck, guys.
Alright, that's it.
Greiner: Good luck,
and good luck with your health.
♪♪
Obviously, we didn't get
a deal, and it hurts,
but at the end of the day,
like, we're fighters.
We know this is
going to be okay.
Like, we're going
to get through it.
We've gotten through
so much together
that we're the, like,
poster children
of just pushing through
no matter what.
Yeah.
So, it doesn't matter
what happened today.
I'm a big believer that
everything happens for a reason
and we're just thankful
for this opportunity,
and we know that
it's going to get us
exactly where
we're meant to be.
Narrator:
Next into the Tank is a product
to take your victories
to the next level.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Matt Walsh,
and I am addicted
to winning.
And I'm Dax Holt, and I fully
support his addiction.
And we are here
seeking $600,000
for 8% of our company,
TrophySmack.
Over 50 million Americans
pour their hearts and souls
into fantasy sports every year
for a chance at victory.
Friends battle it out
for months on end,
smack talking
one another,
investing ridiculous amounts
of time and energy
for the winner
to walk away with what,
empty bragging rights,
a generic Little League trophy?
I don't know about you, Sharks,
but when I win,
I want everyone to know.
And that is why
we created TrophySmack,
the best place to get
the most unique
and customizable
fantasy sports trophies,
blinged‐out rings,
and over‐the‐top
championship belts.
I mean, imagine walking into
your next draft party
with this bad boy
on your shoulder.
Whoo!
So, it's super simple.
You go to our website,
you choose your sport,
then your size and your color.
There are literally
thousands
of trophy combinations
to choose from
to create your very own
dream trophy.
So, we understand
how important winning is
here inside the Tank.
So, we went ahead
and we custom‐designed trophies
for each one
of you Sharks.
Wow.
So, go ahead and unveil
the greatness next to you.
Wow.
I like mine.
A golden slipper.
O'Leary: A bull and bear.
Stock market, baby. Wall Street.
Cuban: I actually like
the one I already have
that's in my office.
[ Laughter ]
How did you guys
come up with this?
So, it happened
in the most organic way.
Credit card out, looking
for something awesome.
I'm in the finals.
I'm the new guy
in the league
with all the dad friends,
and it didn't exist.
So, just joking
with the guys,
I said, "Hey, guys.
I wanted to just get
a six‐foot trophy,
and I wanted to ride it in
like a pony
to show you guys
how much I obliterated you all.
But since it doesn't exist,
I have to start my own now."
But I don't get why
that doesn't exist.
I have ordered trophies
for my business my whole life,
every type of trophy.
Why couldn't you use
a regular trophy house?
What's the difference
here?
So, the trophies
that exist today,
just sort of that
same antique‐looking ‐‐
Yeah, with the guy
with the ‐‐ you know,
standing on top.
Exactly. Everyone was kind of
selling the same thing,
so when we came
onto the scene,
we were the first company
where we had the ability
for someone to change the colors
on the fly,
change the side
on the fly.
John: That does look cool,
I will say.
Did you design it?
We design everything.
So, what are
your backgrounds?
Professor of mine
gave me invaluable advice.
He said, "Matt,
if you want to be
a really successful
entrepreneur,
you need to get into
supply chain and logistics
to really figure out
how businesses operate
and how they function
and execute."
So, first job
out of college,
I took a job
at a freight brokerage.
I rose to the top
of the company in two years.
Wow.
I was the number one
salesperson in the company.
Cuban: It brings up
a good lesson for people.
Whatever you're doing,
be the best at it.
Be the best at it, yeah.
Because once you're the best
at something,
every door opens up
and then you learn where
you can be a great entrepreneur.
So, good for you for focusing
on being great at what you did.
Absolutely.
My background is completely
the opposite.
I come from TV and film
doing entertainment news, "TMZ."
How much did you invest in
this business to get it going?
We invested $250,000.
Whoa.
Wow.
That's a lot of money.
Why do you have to invest that
much to get this going?
That's not messing around.
What is it
you spent your money on?
Walsh: So, in the beginning,
we started small.
Initially, it was
a $60,000 injection,
and in the first three weeks
of getting into the fantasy
football draft season,
sold out of everything.
What's the average cost?
The average price
is about $150, $160.
What does it cost you
to make it?
Our average profit margin
is 80%.
80%?
Wow.
Dang.
Can you walk through the revenue
growth first year,
what you sold,
what you made?
So, Year 1,
January 2018,
we did $850,000
of revenue.
Amazing.
Your first year?
Wow.
What did you make?
What did you make on the 850?
The first year, we had
about a $200,000 net
that we just rolled right into
inventory for Year 2.
Okay.
And then next year ‐‐ '19?
And then,
Year 2, 2019,
we did $1.9 million.
Wow.
Okay, and you made
what on that?
We had $775,000
gross profit,
and we netted
around $500,000.
And this year,
what are you going to do?
Year to date?
Walsh: So, in spite
of the pandemic,
our revenues year to date
are up over last year.
We've done $650,000
revenue so far.
The opportunity for us
is a lot broader than fantasy.
So, corporate awards,
employee recognition, U sports.
But there has to be a ton of
competition in that space.
A ton.
There's a reason
why no one
in the trophy and award space
has really taken
a national approach
on e‐commerce.
The traditional way of
building trophies is crazy.
The assembly process
in our first year ‐‐
Was a nightmare.
Assembly was more expensive
than cost of goods.
The way that we developed
our columns,
the assembly time
was cut down by 90%.
Now I get it.
You're a logistics guy.
Yeah.
Everybody else in this space
can't do what you do
because anybody else would
take years to get up to speed
to where you are.
Correct.
Yeah.
Okay, guys,
so I really respect people
who play sports.
People that are sports fans,
I kind of respect them.
Fantasy guys ‐‐ whew.
[ Laughter ]
So, let me tell you
a story.
I was trying to date
this really hot woman.
I didn't realize she never
had a date on Sunday
'cause these morons were
so busy watching sports.
So, no matter where I was at
in the world,
I would make sure
that I got to New York on Sunday
to take out
this smoking hot woman.
And I remember her telling me,
you know,
"I really don't like guys
who like sports
'cause, you know,
I'm alone on Sundays."
And I said, "I will never watch
a sports game my entire life
if you marry me,"
and I'm married now.
That's awesome.
So...
I'm out.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
Guys, look,
I'm going to make you an offer.
I'll give you $600,000
for 25%
of the business,
and my value is to try
and work it
into the corporate market,
which isn't that easy.
But wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
What do you want the money for,
and what is it that you need?
We're looking for a strategic
partner, right?
We don't want to just continue
doubling every year.
We want to 10x.
Matt, what would
the strategic partner bring you?
So, whether it's opening up
the doors at arenas
for products
within the stadiums,
right,
commemorative rings.
Are you here
just for Cuban?
I think so.
No, we are not.
What do you want to do,
Mark?
What is Mark doing?
Cuban: So, guys, I mean,
I like what you're doing.
I like the fact
that you're hustlers, right,
and you're looking to touch
all the pieces
and you're just
following the money.
The question is,
8% isn't enough.
I'll make you an offer.
I'll offer you
the $600,000
but I want...17%.
Appreciate the offer.
Thank you very much.
And it's either a yes or no,
because ‐‐
No, I'm going to
make you an offer.
There you go.
Then I'm out.
Whoa!
That was a fast
yes or no.
Corcoran: You didn't
even answer. That's unfair.
Shot clock. Shot clock.
Shot clock. Whoa.
Mark, they didn't even
answer her. That's not fair.
You might as well.
Cuban: Unless you want to
say yes, you know.
So it's your decision,
right?
So I'll tell you my offer.
I'll tell you my offer.
Let's take the deal.
Deal.
Done.
Let's go.
Holt: Deal.
Alright, Lori.
John: Aw. That was like
taking candy from a baby.
I had such
a good offer for you.
You should be
ashamed of yourself.
He put us on the spot
too hard.
You know what?
It's good to be the king.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, buddy!
[ Laughs ]
Dream since
the beginning, man.
I've been watching "Shark Tank"
since Season 1.
This is surreal.
We're partners
with Mark Cuban!
[ Both laugh ]
♪♪